poaching has been an illegal practice
for hundreds of years
but it was during the late middle ages
that poaching became a punishable
offence
during this time the right to hunt was
limited to landowners
and royalty in the 1900s
the new european colonial states enacted
preservation laws that would stop the
majority of africans from hunting
this meant that most forms including the
hunting of food were officially deemed
as poaching
however this was the time where
commercial poaching started to become
prevalent
and a threat to animal populations
after independence was gained in the
1950s and 60s
most african countries retained these
laws but poaching for food continued
as well as the poaching for commercial
gain those hunting for food present a
threat to animal populations
but not on the same level as those who
did so for international markets
in the early 2000s the asian demand for
ivory began to rise steeply
and poaching in africa rose to crisis
levels
the impact of poaching isn't limited to
the endangerment and extinction of
animals being hunted
earth's ecosystems are sensitive the
eradication of one species can lead to
the endangerment of another
smaller communities who rely on tourism
will quickly find themselves without
anything to show
but probably the least talked about
impact that poaching can have
is on the health of humanity across the
globe illegal poaching has been linked
to several recent diseases
that have heavily impacted the quality
of life across regions far beyond the
point of the initial hunt
for example the outbreak of sars in hong
kong has been traced to the human
contact
and consumption of poached meat
available on the black wildlife markets
ebola one of the world's most horrific
diseases has had outbreaks in africa
directly linked to the poaching and
consumption
of primates and bird flu monkey pox
and heartwater disease are examples of
diseases directly facilitated by the
illegal wildlife trade
according to the u.s center for disease
control 75 percent of diseases
are zoonotic and reach humans through
animals
and given that illegal smugglers won't
exactly be concerned about effectively
monitoring and quarantining their
international imports
this is an incredibly difficult problem
to control
government efforts to combat poaching is
vastly under-resourced
and ineffective but in recent times
there have been numerous local
community-based groups that have stood
up
and established themselves as national
caretakers of the animal reserves
these organizations have had to ensure
that their training and equipment
is up to the task of keeping up to the
speed with the forever evolving nature
of those involved with the illegal trade
after the reactivation of team rainbow
in 2015 one of these caretakers was
recruited to bring her skills and
expertise to assist in the fight against
terrorism on a global scale
this operator was named melusi
a true predator strikes out of necessity
not
greed and they protect what is theirs
[Music]
fandue and love codenamed melusi
is a defending operator in team rainbow
born in the small south african town
of loewsburg near the athala game
reserve malusi spent many years
exploring the rugged surrounding
landscape with a friend
elna gardner initially brought together
after finding out that both of their
names essentially meant the same thing
beloved they quickly discovered that
they also had a shared passion for the
animals of the game reserve
as they grew up their sense of
appreciation and responsibility for the
animals only increased
they saw the devastation to the park's
animal population as a result of the
greed and cold indifference of the
poachers
every year the threat to the wildlife
rose and they knew that they had to take
action
although they could only save so many
with their limited resources
and the poachers and their victims were
countless
the inhumane and senseless slaughter
drove their determination
their focus and their passion to
concentrate solely on the lives they
could save
eventually elner went on to become an
accomplished veterinarian whereas malusi
chose the path of prevention
and thus joined the south african
national defence force
the role of the south african national
defence force is border protection
and preventing illegal immigration and
drug smuggling they also focus on
serious crimes
such as a tax on farms stock theft
prevention of trafficking drugs
weapons and ammunition car hijackings
and taxi violence
her aim was to broaden her skill set but
also to generate the funds she required
to pay for field ranger training
this one year course involves a number
of different eco-training camps in south
africa and botswala
which teaches its participants expert
knowledge of the african flora and fauna
as well as professional safari guiding
half of the training is spent as an
intern in a lodge to gain profound
hands-on guide experience she also
learned about geology
astronomy weather and climate animal
identification and behaviour
and conservation management
eventually she was noticed by the one
parachute battalion
the only full-time paratrooper unit of
the south african army
to give would-be members the endurance
and fitness they would need for
operations
in the harsh african conditions soldiers
were put through a grueling regime of
psychological and physical tests
including physical training three times
a day no walking in camp under any
circumstances
20 kilometer runs carrying tarp holes
dragging car tyres
carrying a 25 kg concrete slab
everywhere the candidate goes
night runs with 25 kilos of equipment
20 kilometer 75 kilo stretcher runs
digging trenches and the carrying of
artillery canisters
over 10 kilometers all while being timed
after the six month ordeal the select
few obtain their wings
but it doesn't stop here individuals are
required to continue honing their skills
in advanced driving demolitions tactics
and patrolling
unarmed combat survival skills escape
invasion
trafficking counter-insurgency
operations and
ambush and anti-ambush techniques
but unfortunately once active her time
with this unit was short-lived
winner battalion participated in the
south african military assistance to the
central african republic operation
ambushed by the seleka rebels the unit
suffered greatly
with 13 killed 27 injured and one
missing in action
malusi was one of the soldiers left
badly wounded by the event
and lucky to have escaped with her life
although the one parachute battalion
would eventually receive battle honours
for this operation a few years later
it's clear that this event has had a
huge impact on her even today she still
refuses to speak on what happened
and remains forever changed and haunted
by the incident
still in close contact elner eventually
reached out to melusi
asking for her help in defending malue
infilozy park
the oldest and only state-run nature
reserve in africa
home to africa's big five game elephant
rhinoceros
cape buffalo lion and leopard it was
faced with a rapidly growing poacher
threat
melusi resigned from the military and
began training local women
in trafficking interception and
surveillance
together they became the driving force
behind the incubator task force
anti-poaching unit
even after everything she had seen in
the defence force melusi seemed to be
more affected by what she witnessed on
the reserve
and armed with her extensive training
she tackled this new enemy with a
military-like precision
setbacks altercations and tragedy only
pushed her further
and this showed in the way that she
trained the woman and the new drone
surveillance systems that she rolled out
to assist in the fight but the poachers
were also evolving with the times
becoming more militarized they were
forever changing their tactics
and using more specialized equipment
this meant that malusi had to be highly
adaptive
she would wait intercept and prevent
in turn she would become the poacher of
poachers
this method was met with a number of
different reactions even if she wasn't
able to stop them herself
she would often slow them down enough to
be intercepted by others or even
discourage the poachers from continuing
altogether
melusi is a warden she watches she
defends
and she gets the job done she is
efficient
precise and understands that greed
remains one of humanity's greatest
challenges
melusi strongly believes that fighting
the poachers isn't enough
but that in order to move forward in
this fight that there must be education
and a shared responsibility within the
community
if the future is to ever really change
she is proud of the accomplishments that
a team of women have managed to achieve
and she believes they've truly made a
difference in the lives of the animals
they protect
she understands that the local economy
needs help but that this form of
acquiring easy money
isn't the way and in the long term
cannot be sustained
melusi's drive and determination is of
huge benefit to rainbow
her methods of focusing on the action of
prevention through surveillance
and putting an end to the incident
before it can occur will always be the
preferred method to picking up the
pieces after the devastation
[Music]
this one was a little different to the
other operators i've covered up until
now
although melusi came from a military
background the majority of the story
focused on her love and the need to
protect animals in the country she calls
home
so instead i focused on this this is
actually a particular area of interest
for me
the environment and especially the
animals i mean
i'm no greta not by a long shot but this
is probably the reason my house looks
like a petting zoo half the time
anyway thank you very much for watching
i hope you've enjoyed it and i'll catch
in the next one
cheers
[Music]
you